there is a new intelligence warning that
Russia is interfering again in a u.s.
presidential election partly to improve
mr. Trump's 20/20 re-election chances
now this news is bringing a denial from
the Kremlin and fury from President
Trump CBS News has confirmed that last
week US intelligence officials briefed
lawmakers about new Russian meddling
efforts one senior administration
official told CBS News the president
quote blew his stack
when he learned that the House Committee
including top Democrats had been briefed
this week the president removed his
Acting Director of National Intelligence
the official overseeing the nation's 17
spy agencies Paula reads at the White
House Paula what are sources telling you
about the White House reaction to the
briefings
good morning Anthony I am told the
president was furious that McGuire
allowed one of his subordinates to brief
House lawmakers on this intelligence
that allegedly suggests that Russia
favors Trump in 2020 I'm told the
president is concerned that this could
be weaponized against him in the general
election now Democrats are calling for
more hearings while Republicans are
questioning the strength of this
intelligence at a campaign rally in
Colorado President Trump
ignored reports that Russia was trying
to help him get reelected multiple
sources tell CBS News that intelligence
officials warned lawmakers and the White
House that Russians are continuing their
efforts to interfere in the 2020
election a senior administration
official tells CBS News the president
repeatedly called it bull and complained
that the information could be used
against him by Democrats like Adam
Schiff the House Intelligence Chairman
who led the president's impeachment case
weighed in tweeting the president is
again jeopardizing our efforts to stop
foreign meddling but Republican
officials challenged the depth
credibility and scope of the evidence
everybody was talking about how the new
thing is oh they're back to Russia again
nobody's gonna believe this garbage
echoing the same attacks President Trump
has launched for two years
President Trump has repeatedly
challenged his own intelligence
officials and instead sided with Russia
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be just this
month his own FBI director Christopher
ray warned Russia is still intent on
interfering in u.s. elections we
certainly are seeing and and I've never
stopped seeing really since 2016 efforts
to engage in malign foreign influence by
the Russians CBS News has learned the
president was furious that his acting
director of intelligence Joseph McGuire
allowed the briefing without mr. Trump's
knowledge on Wednesday the president
announced McGuire would be replaced with
US ambassador to Germany Richard
Grinnell the choice was blasted by
Democrats like Jim Hines a man with zero
intelligence experience to be to sit
atop the intelligence community of the
United States
White House officials insists that
McGuire's owl sting was merely
coincidental
they also say that Grinnell's
appointment is merely temporary last
night President Trump said he will soon
name a permanent director one name
that's been floated is representative
Doug Collins of Georgia he's one of the
president's most ardent supporters but
this morning he said he's not interested
Anthony well a Roger stone a longtime
associate of President Trump was
sentenced yesterday how is mr. Trump
responding to that sentencing well
Anthony we know the president has a
vested interest in this case yesterday
stone was hen's to three years and four
months in prison but he still left the
courthouse with a big smile on his face
because he remains a free man while he
continues to fight for a new trial the
judge overseeing his case has been
targeted by President Trump on Twitter
she reminded folks yesterday that stone
was prosecuted for covering up for the
president she also called stones actions
a threat to democracy but shortly after
the sentencing president Trump signaled
he may be open to pardoning his longtime
friend though he said he would prefer
that stone be exonerated through the
formal appeals process though based on
the evidence presented at trial that
seems unlikely Anthony all right
Paulette thanks Paul